[Music]
as one of the most notorious gangsters
in history
al capone presided over a fast and
profitable
empire of organized crime but when he
was finally put on trial
the most he could be convicted of was
tax evasion
the nearly 100 million dollars a year
that's 1.4
billion in today's currency the capone
had earned from illegal gambling
bootlegging brothels and extortion
would have served as evidence of his
crimes but the mummy
was nowhere to be found capone and his
associates
had hidden it through investments in
various businesses whose ultimate
ownership
couldn't be proven like cash only
laundromats
in fact those laundromats are part of
the reason
for the name of this activity money
laundering
money laundering came to be the term for
any process
that cleans illegally obtained funds
of their dirty criminal origins allowing
them to be used within the legal economy
but capone wasn't the first to launder
money
in fact this practice is about as old as
itself merchants hid their riches from
tax collectors
and pirates sought to sell their bounty
without drawing attention to how they
got it
with the recent arrival of virtual
currencies
offshore banking the dark net and global
markets
schemes have become much more complex
although modern money laundering methods
vary greatly
most share three basic steps placement
layering and integration
placement is where illegally obtained
money
is converted into assets that seem
legitimate
that's often done by depositing funds
into a bank account
registered to an anonymous corporation
or a professional
middleman this step is where criminals
are often
most vulnerable to detection since they
introduce
massive wealth into the financial system
seemingly out of nowhere
the second step layering involves using
multiple transactions
to further distance the funds from their
origin
this can take the form of transfers
between multiple accounts
or the purchase of tradable property
like expensive cars
artwork and real estate casinos
where large sums of money change hands
every second
are also popular venues for layering
a money launderer may have their
gambling balance made available
at a casino chains locations in other
countries
or work with employees to rig games
the last step integration allows clean
money to re-enter the mainstream economy
and to benefit the original criminal
they might invest it into a legal
business
claim payment by producing fake invoices
or even
start a bogus charity placing themselves
on the board of directors
with an exorbitant salary money
laundering itself
wasn't officially recognized as a
federal crime in the united states until
before that point the government needed
to prosecute a related crime
like tax evasion from 1986 on
they could confiscate wealth simply by
demonstrating
that concealment had occurred which had
a positive effect on prosecuting
major criminal operations like drug
traffickers
however the legal shift has raised
concerns
involving privacy and government
surveillance
today the united nations national
governments
and various non-profits fight against
money laundering
yet the practice continues to play a
major role
in global crime and the most high
profile instances of money laundering
have involved not just private
individuals
but major financial institutions and
government officials no one knows for
sure
the total amount of money that's
laundered on a yearly basis
but some organizations estimated to be
in the hundreds
of billions of dollars
you